المترجم: Abdellatif ZOUMHANE
المدقّق: Fatima Zahra El Hafa
إنه لمن دواعي سروري أن أتحدث إليكم ككل مرة
عن بحثنا.
سأتحدث لكم اليوم عن واجبنا
لحماية أحد الأدوية
الذي أنقد حياة الكثيرين.
فاليوم علينا حماية المضادات الحيوية
التي أنقدت أرواح الملايين
ممن أصيبوا بتعفنات.
فالتعفنات لم تعد بالأمر المخيف بالنسبة لنا
حيث أصبحنا نأخد المضادات الحيوية
فور إصابتنا بمرض ما فنشفى،
على خلاف ما كان عليه الأمر
قبل ظهور المضادات الحيوية سنة 1950.
حيث كان احتمال موت مريض مصاب بتعفن
قد يتجاوز 50 بالمئة.
المقصود بالتعفن
ما يحدث للنساء بعد الولادة،
أو ما يحدث لشخص بعد قيامه بعملية جراحية،
أو التعفنات الناتجة عن الجروح الخارجية
دون الحديث عن الجراحات الدقيقة،
والجراحات القلبية
التي لا يمكن القيام بها دون حدوث تعفن.
وإن لم تكن هناك مضادات حيوية،
ما الذي سيحدث؟
فاليوم علينا حماية المضادات الحيوية
بسبب ظهور بكتيريا مقاومة
ذات مناعة ضد جميع الأدوية.
هذا النوع من البكتيريا
لا تجدي معه الأدوية نفعًا، فيموت الإنسان.
فاليوم يسقط مئات الآلاف من القتلى
عبر العالم
بسبب إصابتهم بتعفن ناتج عن هذا النوع
من البكتيريا المقاومة.
السؤال المطروح هو: ما مصدر هذا النوع
من البكتيريا المقاومة للأدوية؟
فالمضادات الحيوية تعمل وفقًا لنظام معين،
وكلما استعملناها،
نشجع ظهور البكتيريا المقاومة للأدوية.
فما هو الحل؟
الحل يكمن في تجنب استعمال المضادات الحيوية
إلا في حالة الضرورة؟
فلا يجب استعمالها مع بعض الأمراض البسيطة
كالزكام مثلًا.
حتى في حالة وصفها من طرف الطبيب المعالج
سواء بالنسبة لنا أو لأطفالنا،
يجب أن نسأله عما إذا كان تناولها ضروريًّا.
إذا لم يكن الأمر كذلك،
فبإمكاننا الاستغناء عنها.
فيجب التريث وعدم استعمالها
إلا في حالة الضرورة.
اللهم إلا إذا كان الامتناع عن تناولها
يُشكل خطرًا على حياتنا.
فهذا هو الحل الذي اتفق عليه الجميع
والذي يبدو سهل التطبيق.
لكنه لم يعط أي نتيجة رغم مرور 25 سنة،
وبالتالي وجب البحث عن حلول بديلة،
لإنقاد المضادات الحيوية قبل أن نفقدها،
فنمر لعصر ما بعد المضادات الحيوية.
الذي سيكون شبيهًا بعصر
ما قبل المضادات الحيوية،
أي الوقت الذي لم تتوفر فيه
المضادات الحيوية.
فنحن المسؤولون اليوم عن إيجاد حل
لمشكل مقاومة الجراثيم للعديد من الأدوية،
المشكل اليوم هو أن استعمال المضادات
الحيوية لم يعد يقتصر على الإنسان فقط،
بل تعطى للحيوانات كذلك،
ليس المريض منها فحسب،
بل تعطى للملايير من طيور الدجاج،
والملايين من رؤوس الأبقار والأغنام،
لتسريع نموها
وبالتالي تحقيق الربح الكبير والسريع.
وتعطى للنباتات كذلك،
فالمبيدات الحشرية المستعملة
هي أيضًا عبارة عن مضادات حيوية،
حيث تشجع على ظهور الجراثيم المقاومة
في التربة المستعملة في الزراعة،
وبالتالي عند تناول اللحم والبيض والحليب،
وكذلك عند تناول الخضراوات
كالبطاطا والسلطات،
نتناول معها بطريقة غير مباشرة
هذه البكتيريا متعددة المقاومة،
عندما تصل هذه الأخيرة لأمعائنا،
تقوم بتوريث خاصية المقاومة
لبلايين البكتيريا المتواجدة في الأمعاء،
ونحمل في أجسادنا هذه الجراثيم المقاومة،
وعندما نصاب بالتهاب ما،
لا يجدي معه الدواء نفعًا.
هذا ما دفع المجتمع المدني في الدول الغنية،
للضغط على منظمة الصحة العالمية،
ومنظمة الأغذية والزراعة العالمية،
التي ضغطت بدورها على البرلمان الأروبي،
ونتيجة لذلك تم إصدار قوانين
تمنع استعمال المضادات الحيوية
في علف الحيوانات،
وتمنع العديد من المبيدات الحشرية
وتقلص من مجال استعمالها في الدول الغنية.
الشيء الذي أعطى نتائج إيجابية في هذه الدول
الأمر يختلف تمامًا في الدول الفقيرة.
حيث الحكومات والمجتمع المدني،
لا يحركون ساكنًا وكأن الأمر لا يعنيهم.
وكأن الإنسان لا قيمة له في هذه المجتمعات.
والأدهى من ذلك، وجود فئات غنية
داخل هذه المجتمعات تملك رؤوس أموال كبيرة،
وعوض أن تخلق فرصًا للشغل،
أو تشجع البحث العلمي،
يستغلون هذه الأموال في شراء
الأدوية الممنوعة داخل الدول المتقدمة،
من الشركات المتعددة الجنسيات،
وبيعها داخل مجتمعاتهم،
مما يدر عليهم أموالًا طائلة،
وذلك على حساب صحة المستهلك.
ومن يدفع الثمن في الأخير؟
حكومات هذه الدول
التي تكون مضطرة لمعالجة المرضى
ضحايا هذه الأدوية المستوردة الممنوعة.
السؤال المطروح هو كيف يحصل هؤلاء
على رخصة استيراد وتسويق هذه الأدوية؟
الأمر سهل، يحذر هؤلاء حكومات بلدانهم
من خطر منع استيراد هذه الأدوية،
فمثلًا منع المضادات الحيوية
سيؤدي إلى ارتفاع ثمن الدجاج.
نفس الأمر يسري على البطاطس
عند منع استيراد المبيدات الحشرية،
وليس هناك بديل.
أنا هنا كباحث أصبح مسؤولًا
عن إيجاد حل بديل لهؤلاء،
فتزيد أرباح الفلاحين،
دون إلحاق الضرر بصحة المستهلك.
سنة 1987 عند عودتي للمغرب
بعد إنهاء مشواري الدراسي،
قابلت أطباء وبيطريين وصيادلة،
خصوصًا الأطباء، الذين أخبرتهم عن رغبتي
في التخصص في أحد المجالات كباحث،
واسفسرتهم عن أي مجال أختار.
فأجمعوا على أن ما كان يؤرق الأطباء حينها
هو إيجاد حل لمشكل مقاومة المضادات الحيوية،
سمعت على أفواههم قصصًا مؤلمة
أجبرتني على التخصص في هذا المجال.
ورغم انعدام الإمكانات داخل الجامعات آنداك،
قمنا بعدة بحوث رفقة أساتذة من المغرب،
مستعنين بخبرة باحثين من الخارج،
دون إنكار دور العشرات من الطلبة الباحثين
في سلك الدكتوراه والماستر،
فلولاهم لما وصلنا لما نحن عليه الآن.
وأنا أحييهم على هذا الدور.
(تصفيق)
فعبر العالم، أساس البحث العلمي هو الطلبة،
وكمثال على ذلك المغرب.
اليوم وصلنا لحلول عجيبة وبسيطة.
الانطلاقة كانت من ملاحظة بسيطة،
من النباتات العطرية
كالزعتر والقرنفل والنعناع،
التي لا تصاب بالميكروبات،
فهذه النباتات تنتج ما يسمى
بالزيوت الأساسية.
التي تحتوي على جزيئات عطرية
قادرة على قتل الميكروبات،
حيث تلعب نفس دور المضادات الحيوية.
وعند دراستنا للجزيئات العطرية
وجدنا أنها فعالة أكثر من المضادات الحيوية،
لكونها تقضي على الجراثيم
بطريقة تفقد معه هذه الأخيرة صفة المقاومة،
فنحصل على فعالية المضادات الحيوية
والقدرة على القضاء على مقاومة الجراثيم،
وهذا ما نطمح للوصول إليه.
فقمنا باستغلال هذه الأسلحة
التي تستعملها النباتات للدفاع عن النفس،
وأعطيناها للإنسان والحيوان،
لمحاربة الالتهابات،
وكذلك النباتات غير القادرة
على إنتاج الزيوت الأساسية.
اليوم نتوفر على منتوجات
يتم تصنيعها داخل المعامل بكمية كافية،
ونعطيها للفلاحين
الذين يُربّون الحيوانات كالدجاج.
الذين عبروا عن رضاهم.
حيث أعطت نتائج أفضل من المضادات الحيوية،
كما عبروا لي شخصيًا عن ارتياحهم،
لأنهم أصبحوا يسوّقون منتوجات
لا تشكل أي ضرر على المستهلك.
فيما قبل كانوا يبيعون منتجاتهم للآخرين،
دون استعمالها داخل بيوتهم.
عكس ما أصبح عليه الأمر الآن.
نفس الشيء مع المزارعين،
فهناك منتوج نسوّقه
للكبار والصغار منهم على حد سواء،
والذي أعطى نتائج أفضل من المبيدات الحشرية.
على سبيل المثال، مرض البيّوض
الذي يصيب النخيل،
حيث أعطت هذه المنتوجات الطبيعية
نتائج فعالة في القضاء على هذا المرض،
بالنسبة للإنسان،
هناك دواء تصنعه شركة مغربية،
وليست شركة متعددة الجنسيات كما هو معتاد،
حيث خضع لجميع المراحل التي تمر منها
الأدوية بما في ذلك التحليلات السريرية،
وأظهر فعاليته في هذه التحليلات
عند العشرات من المرضى
المصابين بعدوى جرثومة متعددة المقاومة،
إذ ساعد على شفائهم.
سيُطرح هذا الدواء في الأسواق
في القريب العاجل بعد الحصول على الرخصة.
وسيكون أول دواء في تاريخ المغرب
نتيجة بحت مغربي،
وطورته شركة صناعية مغربية.
(تصفيق)
هذا الدواء لديه براءة اختراع في المغرب
وأمريكا وأوروبا، وجميع جهات العالم.
براءة الاختراع هذه تمت المصادقة عليها،
مما سيمكننا من تصدير هذه المنتجات،
حتى تلك المخصصة للنبات والحيوانات...
(تصفيق)
سنصدرها للدول الغنية.
وبالتالي سنقوم بما يطلق عليه
الابتكار المضاد.
ويعني أن الابتكار يكون في دول الجنوب
وينتقل لدول الشمال،
مما سيتيح لنا الاصطفاف إلى جانب دول
من قبيل البرازيل والأرجنتين والهند.
حتى يبقى المغرب بلد الشباب والطموح
إلى جانب هذه الدول.
اليوم نتحدث عن قصة نجاح،
وقصص النجاح شيء نادر
سواء في الدول الغنية أو الفقيرة،
وعندما تحدث يجب ألا نفرّط فيها أو نضيعها،
يجب أن نتحد جميعًا لإنجاحها
لتصبح شيئًا ملموسًا،
ودعمها من الناحية المادية والإدارية
حتى لا تموت.
فالتفريط فيها سيعرضها للموت،
أو سيقوم حاملوها بترك أوطانهم
والبحث عن مكان آخر لتطوير قصة نجاحهم.
ليس حقدًا على أصولهم،
لكن بسبب غياب المساندة والدعم الضرورين،
لم يجدوا صناديق دعم تمول أفكارهم،
وغياب وسائل تكنولوجية حديثة داخل الجامعات.
اليوم وأنا أتحدث عن النجاح،
ما أود نقله للشباب والأطفال،
هو أننا قادرون على تحقيق أحلامنا
في هذا الوطن الذي نعيش فيه.
شخصيًّا، ما وصلت إليه يفوق بكثير
ما كنت أطمح إليه في البداية.
ليس ذلك بالأمر السهل
بل يتطلب الكثير من المثابرة والعمل.
فلكل مشكل حل مهما اشتدت صعوبته،
عليكم فقط بالإرادة والمثابرة.
(تصفيق)
ولكي نصل لما نطمح إليه،
يجب أن نكون أشخاصًا إيجابيين في حياتنا،
لكي نبني مَغربًا إيجابيًّا،
فقد سئمنا مما يُتداول
في مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي من سوداوية،
نحن لا نؤمن بالسلبية،
بل بكل ما هو إيجابي وباعث على الطموح.
عندما نبني مغربًا إيجابيًّا وطموحًا،
حينها سنحقق النجاحات.
وإذا كنا نقول اليوم سوف ننجح،
غدًا سنقول نعم نجحنا.
شكرًا لكم.
(تصفيق)